This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Being a celebrity can be boiled down to a simple formula. Follow these rules and you can be an a-lister too. Rule number one, go to the right parties. It's the year's most electrifying red carpet with a spoon-shape. Rule number two, hang out with the right people. The most successful singers in the biz, Selena Gomez and Taylor Swift. I mean, the two have been BFS for like, ever.
这里是《隐藏的脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当名人其实可以归结为一个简单的公式。遵循这些规则，你也可以成为一线明星。规则一，去对的派对。这是年度最具震撼力、勺子形状的红毯。规则二，和对的人交往。业内最成功的歌手，赛琳娜·戈麦斯和泰勒·斯威夫特。我是说，这两人可以说是永远的闺蜜。
Rule number three. Be seen, but in small doses. Over exposure, as we know, actually does make people lose interest. Rule number four. Never go to Vegas. What are you talking about Vegas? Vegas, baby, Vegas! If you go to Las Vegas, it actually pulls your star power down. Now maybe you're thinking, this episode isn't for me. I'm not an a-lister, I've no desire to be one. I don't read us weekly or keep up with the Kardashians.
规则三。增加曝光，但要适度。正如我们所知，过度曝光确实会让人们失去兴趣。规则四。永远不要去拉斯维加斯。你在说什么拉斯维加斯？拉斯维加斯，宝贝，拉斯维加斯！如果你去拉斯维加斯，实际上会拉低你的明星光环。现在你可能会想，这一集不适合我。我不是一线明星，也没有当一线明星的想法。我不读《美国周刊》，也不关注卡戴珊家族。
But Elizabeth Card-Halkeh's research into elite social groups might just apply to you too. Elizabeth is a professor of urban planning at the University of Southern California, but if you look at the books she's written, she's actually fascinated by social networks. From Hollywood to the highly educated people who spend their time and money on things like... Yoga, breastfeeding, buying organic food, attending farmers markets listening to NPR, reading the books on the New York Times bestseller list. These are all physical manifestations of your cultural capital. This week on Hidden Brain, elite groups and how our
但伊丽莎白·卡尔-哈尔凯特对精英社交群体的研究可能也适用于你。伊丽莎白是南加州大学的城市规划教授，但如果你看看她写过的书，就会发现她实际上对社交网络着迷。从好莱坞到那些把时间和金钱花在诸如……瑜伽、母乳喂养、买有机食品、逛农夫市场、听NPR、读《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上的人。这些都是你文化资本的物质表现。本周的《隐藏我们的脑》，精英群体以及我们的
choices are shaped by the people around us. When you look at which stars shine the brightest in Hollywood, do you ever wonder why certain people are famous and not others? Talent certainly has something to do with it. Wealth and beauty don't hurt. But in her book, Starstruck, Elizabeth says there's something else at work. One thing that happens with interest fads and fashions
选择是如何被周围的人塑造的。当你看着好莱坞哪些明星最耀眼时，你有没有想过为什么有些人出名而其他人不出名？才华肯定有一定关系。财富和美貌也无伤大雅。但在她的新书《追星族》中，伊丽莎白表示还有其他因素在起作用。兴趣、风潮、时尚
and fixations on particular celebrities is that there is a collective interest, but that collective interest is recursive. Meaning, if lots of people are paying attention to something or someone, that begets more attention. There are complicated reasons for why this is, and one of the things that I think really propels this kind of network effect is that in cultural markets and in taste, which in many ways
以及对特定名人的迷恋发生的一件事是，存在着一种集体兴趣，但这种集体兴趣是递归的。意思是，如果很多人在关注某事或某人，那就会引发更多的关注。背后的原因很复杂，我认为真正推动这种网络效应的原因之一是，在文化市场和品味中——在很多方面
celebrities are a part of a taste-driven market, we look to each other for signals for what to pay attention to. And in many ways, this explains the success of lots of taste-driven things. So whether we're talking about films or music or artwork, are the objects or people who rise to the top really that much better or that much more interesting than everyone else, probably not that much more. The disproportionate win is the function of what economists call a winner-take-all-market, which is that because we're looking for clues, we look at the person next to us and what
名人也是品味驱动市场的一部分——我们互相寻找信号来决定关注什么。在许多方面，这解释了许多品味驱动事物的成功。所以无论我们讨论的是电影、音乐还是艺术品，那些脱颖而出的对象或人真的比其他人好得多或有趣得多吗？可能并没有好那么多。这种不成比例的赢家通吃是经济学家所称的“赢家通吃市场”的一个功能，也就是说，因为我们在寻找线索，我们会看身边的人以及他们在
their pain attention to, and so that then we pay attention to it too, and then someone looks to us. And then it's really hard to say if that thing, whether it's a Mark Rothko painting, or my friend on Facebook, is the thing to pay attention to. But by that point we already are. When Elizabeth Carrott-Halkett talks about celebrities, she isn't talking about all famous people. She makes a distinction between people who are well-known, and people who fascinate us. She makes a distinction between people who are well known and people who fascinate us. Fame is simply people knowing who you are.
关注什么，然后我们也会关注它，接着别人又会看着我们。到了那个时候，真的很难说那个东西——不管是马克·罗斯科的画作，还是我脸书上的朋友——是不是真正值得关注的东西。但到那个时候，我们已经开始关注了。当伊丽莎白·卡尔-哈尔凯特谈论名人时，她指的并不是所有名人。她对知名人士和让我们着迷的人做了区分。她对知名人士和让我们着迷的人做了区分。名气仅仅意味着人们知道你是谁。
And the sheer number of people who know who someone is is very different from a public being fixated upon someone. Oh, that Bill Gates, isn't he in technology? It's very different from what did Bill Gates eat for breakfast today and many, many people wanting to know. It can be bewildering the way we care desperately about the details of some people's lives, but not others.
而且知道某人是谁的人数，与公众对某人的迷恋有着天壤之别。哦，那个比尔·盖茨，他不就是搞技术的吗？这和“比尔·盖茨今天早餐吃了什么”以及许多许多人想知道答案有着极大的不同。我们竟然如此拼命地关心某些人的生活细节，而对其他人漠不关心，这种现象有时令人感到迷惑。
Barack Obama is a popular politician, but not every president becomes a celebrity in the way that he did. I remember reading an article in The New York Times about the number of almonds Obama ate every night after dinner. We know exactly which kind of socks Jennifer Aniston likes to wear, and the type of diet Beyonce followed after the birth of her first child.
巴拉克·奥巴马是一位受欢迎的政治家，但并非每位总统都会像他那样成为名人。我记得在《纽约时报》上读过一篇文章，讲的是奥巴马每天晚饭后吃的杏仁数量。我们确切地知道詹妮弗·安妮斯顿喜欢穿哪种袜子，以及碧昂丝生下第一个孩子后遵循的是哪种饮食。
I think that what has really changed if we think about the evolution of celebrity is that we have access to that material now. So celebrities have existed in some shape or form since probably the beginning of human civilization. We've always been more interested in certain people for things that transcend their talent. And we've been more interested in the personal details of certain people. But in the Hollywood studio system, that was so much more controlled. And today, it's not by virtue of many different things.
我认为，如果我们考虑名人的演变，真正改变的是我们现在能够接触到这些材料。所以名人以某种形式大概从人类文明之初就存在了。我们一直对超越其才华的某些人更感兴趣。而且我们一直对某些人的个人细节更感兴趣。但在好莱坞制片厂体制下，这是受到很大控制的。而今天，由于许多不同的因素，情况已经不再如此。
And so that focus on the number of almonds that President Obama used to eat. I want to say the number is seven. I'm not sure, but I remember that article and being very interested in this. That that is also a product of the fact that we can get that information. Our ability to get that kind of personal information, coupled with the fact that we're drawn to what other people are drawn to, this is a formula for celebrity. We hear that Obama eats seven almonds and that other people care that Obama eats seven almonds, and
因此，对奥巴马总统过去常吃的杏仁数量的关注。我想说数量是七个。我不确定，但我记得那篇文章，并且对此非常感兴趣。这也是我们可以获得这类信息这一事实的产物。我们获取这种个人信息的能力，加上我们会被其他人吸引的东西所吸引这一事实，构成了名人的公式。我们听说奥巴马吃七个杏仁，而其他人也关心奥巴马吃七个杏仁，然后
suddenly this detail seems fascinating. It reminded me of a study that the researchers tanally milk-rimb once conducted in the late 1960s. He had someone walk along a sidewalk in New York City, the person walked down the street, and then suddenly stopped and looked up. The experiment was documented in an educational video. We are all individuals, but we live in a world with other people and we must often accommodate to them. To what extent can we remain individuals in a social world?
突然间这个细节显得格外迷人。这让我想起研究人员斯坦利·米尔格拉姆在20世纪60年代末进行的一项研究。他让一个人沿着纽约市的人行道走，这个人走了一段路后，突然停下来抬头看。这个实验被记录在一部教育视频中。我们都是个体，但我们生活在一个有其他人的世界里，我们经常必须适应他们。在一个社交世界中，我们在多大程度上能保持个体性？
What kinds of pressures do others exert on us to conform? And how do we deal with such pressures? How can social psychology study the issues of independence and conformity? Most pedestrians ignored the man and kept walking, but a few passers-by, about 4%, stopped, and they looked up too. Then the experimenters had a larger group suddenly stopped and looked up. When it wasn't just one person but a group, many more pedestrian stop to look up as well, nearly 20% almost five times more than before. As they increased the size of the initial crowd, they found that the proportion of passers-by who imitated the looking up response also increased. We take our signals about what to pay attention to from one another. If one person is looking up, who cares? But if 10 people are
其他人对我们施加了什么样的顺从压力？我们如何应对这些压力？社会心理学如何研究独立与顺从的问题？大多数行人都忽略了这个人并继续走路，但有几个路人，大约4%，停了下来，他们也抬头看了看。然后实验者让一个更大的群体突然停下来抬头看。当不只一个人而是一个群体时，更多的行人也停下来抬头看，将近20%，几乎是之前的五倍。随着他们增加最初人群的规模，他们发现模仿抬头反应的路人比例也增加了。我们从彼此那里获取关于关注什么的信号。如果一个人在抬头，谁在乎呢？但如果10个人在
looking up, well, there must be something to see. That's exactly right. And there have been a number of different studies since Milgram, where social scientists have looked at this as well. Anita Elbersa did this really interesting study where she argued that big companies like Amazon actually create a collective cohesive fan base for things because they allow us to coalesce around big hits. There's another really interesting study done by Duncan Watts and Matthew Saganek, where they did this fascinating study between two different groups of people listening to music.
抬头，嗯，那一定有什么东西可看。完全正确。自米尔格拉姆以来，还有许多不同的研究，社会科学家也对此进行了研究。安妮塔·埃尔伯斯做了一项非常有趣的研究，她认为像亚马逊这样的大公司实际上通过让我们围绕大热点聚集在一起，为事物创造了一个集体且有凝聚力的粉丝群。邓肯·沃茨和马修·萨加内克做了另一项非常有趣的研究，他们在两组不同的人听音乐之间进行了这项引人入胜的研究。
Let's think about a popular song from a few years ago. Now, the year that called me maybe was released, 2012, there were a number of other pop songs that could have topped the charts. Like, why not this one? Or this one? You could argue that Call Me Maybe was a catchy song, but did you feel that way the first time you heard it? Or was it only after everyone else held up the song as the song of the summer that had started to get stuck in your head? When a song becomes popular, we get signals from lots of people that we should pay attention
让我们想想几年前的一首流行歌曲。现在，在《Call Me Maybe》发行的2012年，还有许多其他流行歌曲本可以登上排行榜榜首。比如，为什么不是这首？或者这首？你可以争辩说《Call Me Maybe》是一首朗朗上口的歌，但你第一次听到它时也是这种感觉吗？还是说只有在其他人把这首歌奉为夏日神曲之后，它才开始在你脑海里挥之不去？当一首歌变得流行时，我们会从很多人那里收到信号，提示我们应该关注
to it. We hear it over, and and over and over again. Then the hooks in our heads. And before we know it, we somehow know all the words. The takeaway was essentially that if you didn't know what other people were listening to, there was much more chaos in the list of the most popular music. It was much more ambiguous, you know, what everyone thought was the best. But if listeners knew what others thought was good, that would actually compound upon itself. And then you got a much clearer list of the most popular songs. At the heart of your book is an argument about how celebrities become celebrities.
它。我们一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地听到它。然后旋律就印在了我们脑海里。不知不觉中，我们竟然记住了所有的歌词。结论基本上是，如果你不知道其他人都在听什么，最受欢迎的音乐名单就会变得更加混乱。大家认为最好听的歌曲要模糊得多。但如果听众知道其他人认为什么是好歌，这种效应就会自我叠加。然后你会得到一份更清晰的最受欢迎歌曲名单。你书的核心是一个关于名人是如何成为名人的论点。
And you say it has a lot to do with being part of a very elite invite-only network. What do you mean by that? So when I started looking at celebrities, I was trying to figure out if there were particular personal attributes, even talent attributes that drove the rise of a celebrity. And it was really hard to come up with them. Simultaneously, I was really trying to understand the social dynamics of people who worked in creative industries. My first book, The World Hall Economy, was about how creative industries worked in New York City. And it was a very qualitative book.
你说这与加入一个非常精英的、仅限受邀者加入的网络有很大关系。你这是什么意思？所以当我开始研究名人时，我试图弄清楚是否存在驱动名人崛起的特定个人属性，甚至是才华属性。要找出这些属性真的很难。与此同时，我真的在努力理解在创意产业工作的人的社会动态。我的第一本书《世界大厅经济》讲的是创意产业如何在纽约市运作。那是一本非常定性的书。
And I found when I spoke to artists and musicians and designers, that despite the fact that they didn't have a lot of money, and that a lot of them needed space to do their work, they felt compelled to live in New York City, even if getting a big warehouse space in Ohio would have served them well in a practical sense that they needed their social lives in New York. And so when I finished that book, I really wanted to get a sense of the social networks and the social knew you in which creative people lived and worked in and how important it was. So I teamed up with my colleague, Gilead Ravead,
我发现，当我与艺术家、音乐家和设计师交谈时，尽管他们没有多少钱，而且他们中的许多人需要空间来完成工作，但他们感到自己不得不住在纽约市，即使在俄亥俄州找一个大仓库空间在实用意义上对他们很有利，但他们觉得自己在纽约需要社交生活。所以当我写完那本书后，我真的很想了解创意人员生活和工作的社交网络和社交圈，以及它是多么重要。所以我与我的同事吉利德·拉维德合作，
and he and I looked at photographic data of celebrities. And we used Getty Images, and we looked at all of the caption information of photographs in their entertainment catalog over the course of one year. And what we tried to do was make sense of not just who was in photographs together, but who went to the same parties, the same events, and where those parties were, and if there was a pattern in who showed up at parties together. So was there a randomness to the photographs? Was there something that drove why people showed up?
他和我都看了名人的照片数据。我们使用了盖蒂图片社，查看了他们娱乐目录中一年内所有照片的标题信息。我们试图弄清楚的不仅是谁一起出现在照片中，还有谁去了相同的派对、相同的活动，这些派对在哪里，以及一起出现在派对上的人是否存在某种模式。那么照片是随机的吗？是什么促使人们出现的原因？
So what we tried to look at was a way to cut things off. So how could we organize all of these people in the database? So what we tried to look at was a way to cut things off. So how could we organize all of these people in the database? So we looked at Forbes star currency, which ranked stars based on their star power. And we divided them into the top 60 into three different groups, A list, B list, C list.
所以我们试图寻找的是一种切断联系的方法。那么我们如何组织数据库中的所有人呢？所以我们试图寻找的是一种切断联系的方法。那么我们如何组织数据库中的所有人呢？因此，我们查看了福布斯明星货币，它根据明星的明星效应进行排名。我们将前60名划分为三个不同的组，一线、二线、三线。
And we then looked at these stars in the photographs, so we corresponded these two different measures. And what we found was that the only group that had a non-random, very closed connected network, a click essentially, were the a list. And that they really reinforced their position by spending time with each other at the same parties over and over again
然后我们观察了照片中的这些明星，我们将这两个不同的指标进行了对应。我们发现，唯一一个拥有非随机、高度紧密连接的网络（基本上是一个派系）的群体是一线明星。他们通过一次又一次地在同一个派对上花时间在一起，真正巩固了自己的地位，
and not spending time with anyone else. It was an A-list recording. I am here with Naomi Watts for the impossible. Best actress, Oscar nominee. Amy Adams, Best Score actress, nominee. Sack, Best Ensemble, nominated. Oscar nominated. Everything nominated. Silver Lines, Playbook. I can't believe this is happening twice.
而不和任何人花时间在一起。这是一场一线录音。我和因《海啸奇迹》而来到这里的娜奥米·沃茨在一起。最佳女主角奥斯卡提名者。艾米·亚当斯，最佳女配角提名者。全体演员，获得提名。获得奥斯卡提名。所有项目都获得提名。《乌云背后的幸福线》。我简直不敢相信这种事发生了两次。
What was also interesting was that the B-list and the C-list did not have those same connections, even with each other. So they had a much more disparate network amongst each other. And in fact, their categories were almost arbitrary. It was really if you were in this top 20 group that you were extraordinarily exclusive and actually perpetuated that exclusivity by spending time just with each other. So if this is the case, then a question arises, which is how does anyone ever crack the A-list club?
同样有趣的是，二线和三线明星并没有那些相同的联系，甚至彼此之间也没有。因此，他们彼此之间的网络更加离散。事实上，他们的分类几乎是随意的。只有当你处于这个前20名的群体时，你才是极其排他的，并且实际上通过只和彼此花时间来维持这种排他性。如果真是这样，那么就会产生一个问题，那就是任何人究竟是如何挤进一线俱乐部的？
If it's essentially a closed club, and the people in the club take great pains to keep others out, and the only way to become an A-list celebrity is to be invited to the club, it creates something of a conundrum, which is how do you actually break into the club? I argue in the book that it's a, you take this kind of quantum leap. So it's not an iterative thing.
如果它本质上是一个封闭的俱乐部，俱乐部里的人费尽心思把其他人挡在外面，而成为一线名人的唯一途径就是被邀请进入俱乐部，这就造成了一个难题，那就是你究竟如何才能挤进这个俱乐部？我在书中争辩说，这是一个，你要实现这种量子飞跃。所以这不是一个迭代的过程。
Like if I just keep toiling away as a bea-less celebrity at some point, I'm going to be a list. That's not how it happens. So something big either happens in your career or big happens in your social life. Like you get married to an a-lister or you suddenly are best friends with an a-lister and in some way they allow you to permeate the a-list. But you can also do it because of your career when I was looking over star-struck
就像如果我作为一个二线明星继续苦苦挣扎，在某个时刻我会成为一线明星。事情不是这样的。所以你的职业生涯中发生了大事，或者你的社交生活发生了大事。比如你嫁给了一线明星，或者你突然成为了一线明星的至交好友，某种程度上他们允许你渗透进一线。但你也可以因为你的职业生涯而做到这一点，当我翻阅《追星族》
in preparation for this interview. I noticed that in this far corner is Zoe Kravitz so she wasn't an a-lister or a B-lister, I think at the time of organizing this, she was a sea-lister in this database. But of course, she's now one of the key stars of Big Little Lies, which is an extraordinarily television show on HBO. People are obsessed with it. She's amazing in it.
为这次采访做准备时。我注意到在这个角落里的是佐伊·克拉维茨，所以在组织这个数据库时，她不是一线或二线明星，我认为她当时是三线明星。但当然，她现在是《大小谎言》的关键明星之一，这是HBO上一档非凡的电视节目。人们对它着迷不已。她在里面棒极了。
Okay. It's shocking. And a bit disturbing. But I think it is important that we separate the nobility of the cause from the misguided means pursuing it. We champion the former and dissuade her from the latter. And so where would she be now? I'd imagine she's probably moving to A-list,
好的。这令人震惊。也有点令人不安。但我认为重要的是，我们要将事业的高尚性与追求它的错误手段区分开来。我们支持前者，并劝阻她不要采取后者。那么她现在会在哪里呢？我想她可能正在迈向一线，
and that's a function of something that happened to her career. And those are the ways in which you permeate it if you're not, you know, a young star is born and you can immediately become an A-lister because you start in this great film and you're, you know, this actress or actor who was just discovered. But the other way is if you're already in the Hollywood machine that you jump in is if you've either connected with someone or you've done something with your career that enables you to leap.
这是她职业生涯中发生的事情的结果。如果你不是那种天生的一线明星——比如一颗新星诞生，你因为出演了一部伟大的电影而立刻成为一线明星，你就是这个刚刚被发现的女演员或男演员——这就是你渗透进去的方式。但另一种方式是，如果你已经身处好莱坞机器中，你的跃升是通过与某人建立联系，或者通过你在职业生涯中所做的事情，从而使你能够实现跨越。
You found that it makes a difference where you get photographed and that there are in fact only three places in the world where it's actually important to get photographed if you want to crack one of these super exclusive clubs. So yes, this was an amazing finding. When we looked at all of the photographic data in our database, and we had something like 600,000 photographic events, or photographs rather, we found that 80% of them were taken in Los Angeles, New York, or London.
你发现你在哪里被拍照是有差别的，事实上，如果你想挤进这些超级独家俱乐部之一，世界上只有三个地方拍照才真正重要。是的，这是一个惊人的发现。当我们查看数据库中的所有 photographic 数据，并且我们大约有60万个 photographic 事件或照片时，我们发现其中80%是在洛杉矶、纽约或伦敦拍摄的。
And that really did mean that in the eyes of the media, which then becomes the eyes of the public, you really had to be geographically bound to these places for people who know who you are and to become a celebrity. Now, of course, some people don't want that. I mean, if you think about someone like Daniel Day-Lewis who's an incredibly revered actor, I think he actually just retired, but he lives out, I think, in the Midwest. He is
这确实意味着，在媒体眼中，进而成为公众眼中，你真的必须在地理上绑定到这些地方，人们才会知道你是谁，你才能成为名人。当然，有些人并不想要这样。我的意思是，如果你想想像丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯这样一位备受尊崇的演员，我想他实际上刚刚退休，但他住在中西部。他
no interest in this. So people know him because he is talented. But he's not a celebrity in the way that the stars who are photographed over and over again are. And we are then able to build an interest and a fixation on them. And so if you are heading to Vegas to get photographed at a big social event, this might actually be something of a strategic mistake. So this was very interesting that there were certain places that really opt star power, and one of those places is, you know, if you go somewhere, you know, international, like Tokyo, and if you're in London for a certain number of days, if you go to Las Vegas, it actually pulls your star power down.
对这毫无兴趣。所以人们认识他是因为他有才华。但他并不是那种一遍又一遍被拍照的明星那样的名人。然后我们能够建立对他们的兴趣和迷恋。因此，如果你前往拉斯维加斯在一个大型社交活动中被拍照，这实际上可能是一个战略错误。所以这非常有趣，有些地方确实会提升明星光环，而其中一个地方是，如果你去某个国际化的地方，比如东京，如果你在伦敦呆了几天，如果你去拉斯维加斯，实际上会拉低你的明星光环。
And I thought a lot about this. And I think one of the things is that it's not a hub for talent-driven star events. And it really is about just partying. And so there is a sense that going to Las Vegas really drives your famous for being famous element. But if you're a bona fide aelister, you're going to the Vanity Fair of Oscar Party,
我对此进行了很多思考。我想其中原因之一是，它不是才华驱动的明星活动中心。它纯粹是关于派对的。因此，人们有一种感觉，去拉斯维加斯确实会推动你“因出名而出名”的元素。但如果你是一个货真价实的一线明星，你会去名利场的奥斯卡派对，
but you're not making your way to some nightclub in Las Vegas. So there's something very sad here, because if you're a beelister or a seaelister and you want to crack the a-list club You know and you're attending the events that you can get into which might be in Las Vegas for example That might actually be hurting your chances to eventually make it into the a-list club Which leads us to the
但你不会去拉斯维加斯的某个夜总会。所以这里有些非常悲哀的事情，因为如果你是一个二线或三线明星，并且你想挤进一线俱乐部，你知道的，你正在参加你能进去的活动——比如可能在拉斯维加斯——这实际上可能会损害你最终进入一线俱乐部的机会。这把我们引向了那个
Dispairing idea that once a bea-lister always a bea-lister Well, I think that's a pretty good observation. It really depends on what your goal is. I mean, if one's goal is to just be, you know, on everyone's radar, to be in the tabloids, and to possibly do something with that recognition, then go to Las Vegas. If your goal is to be revered as one of Hollywood's elite, it's a better idea to stay home. Even if becoming an A-Lister isn't your goal, Elizabeth's research might apply to you.
令人绝望的想法：一旦成为二线明星，就永远是二线明星。嗯，我认为这是一个相当不错的观察。这完全取决于你的目标是什么。我的意思是，如果一个人的目标只是为了，你知道的，出现在每个人的雷达上，登上小报，并可能利用那种知名度做点什么，那就去拉斯维加斯。如果你的目标是被尊为好莱坞精英之一，最好还是待在家里。即使成为一线明星不是你的目标，伊丽莎白的研究也可能适用于你。
After the break, we're going to talk about social forces that are more relevant to your life. That's going to be especially true if your life includes farmers markets, yoga classes, and instantly recognizing this voice. Screen court, if the legal questions were dry, the argument was not. Stay with us. This week, we're talking about elite groups from a list celebrities to a new social elite that Elizabeth Card, Halcad, has dubbed the aspirational class. This elite group is highly educated. Its members breastfeed their children. They spend
休息过后，我们将讨论与你的生活更相关的社会力量。如果你的生活包括农夫市场、瑜伽课，并且能立即认出这个声音，那就更是如此了。法庭，如果法律问题是枯燥的，辩论则不然。请继续收听。本周，我们将讨论精英群体，从一线明星到伊丽莎白·卡尔-哈尔凯特称之为“渴望阶层”的新社会精英。这个精英阶层受过高等教育。其成员母乳喂养他们的孩子。他们把
money on things like organic produce and expensive Pilates classes. We reproduce a Maggie Penman to a hotbed of the aspirational class, a whole food in Washington DC. She adds shoppers a series of seemingly unrelated questions about their habits and choices, and we're going to hear some of their answers throughout this conversation. I think small farmers is really ideally where I would get most of my produce. I try to shop at farmers markets as much as I can. Yeah, organic food definitely because I'm a father of three kids, and I think it's important to give them healthy food.
钱花在诸如有机农产品和昂贵的普拉提课程上。我们让玛吉·彭曼带大家走进渴望阶层的温床，华盛顿特区的一家全食超市。她向购物者询问了一系列看似无关的问题，关于他们的习惯和选择，我们将在接下来的对话中听到其中的一些回答。我认为小农场实际上是我获取大部分农产品理想的地方。我尽可能多地在农夫市场购物。是的，绝对是有机食品，因为我是三个孩子的父亲，我认为给他们提供健康的食物很重要。
For my son I only buy organic food. I always buy organic food if I'm not getting it out of my own garden. I don't want the chemicals, I don't want the pesticides, I don't want things that don't grow naturally from the earth. I do try to make choices that are local, sustainable, good for my body. Now, these are all thoughtful people. When you ask them why they do yoga, they might say something like,
对于我的儿子，我只买有机食品。如果不是从我自己的菜园里摘的，我总是买有机食品。我不想要化学品，不想要杀虫剂，不想要那些不是从大自然中自然生长出来的东西。我确实尽量做出本地的、可持续的、对我的身体有益的选择。现在，这些都是有思想的人。当你问他们为什么做瑜伽时，他们可能会说类似这样的话：
it's good for my health, it's good for stretching. And I like the part that it's got a little bit of a meditative aspect reminding me to just kind of take a break from the day. Why do I do yoga because it makes me feel fabulous? But what if I told you that all of these well-meaning people, making individual choices that are good for them and good for their families, that these people are creating a new social elite?
这对我的健康有好处，对拉伸有好处。我喜欢它有一个微小的冥想方面，提醒我从一天的工作中休息一下。我为什么做瑜伽，因为它让我感觉棒极了！但如果我告诉你，所有这些好心的人，做出对他们自己和家人有利的个人选择，这些人正在创造一个新的社会精英阶层呢？
It signifiers might not be fancy cars or flashy watches, but Elizabeth Currett Halkett says, this club is every bit as exclusive as the A list. I started thinking about this book. Really through being inspired by Thorstein Reblund's book, The Theory of the Leisure Class, which I read many, many years ago as a graduate student and continue to refer to in my later work. And I was fascinated with his ability to characterize day-to-day behavior that revealed social position and economic position. But I also knew that things had changed a lot and these ways in which we
它的标志可能不是豪车或耀眼的手表，但伊丽莎白·卡尔-哈尔凯特说，这个俱乐部和一线明星一样排外。我开始构思这本书。真的是受到托斯坦·凡勃伦的书《有闲阶级论》的启发，我很多年前作为研究生时读过这本书，并在我后来的工作中不断参考它。我对他能够通过描述日常行为来揭示社会地位和经济地位的能力着迷。但我也知道情况已经发生了很大变化，我们展示
showed social position were not material anymore or not entirely material. And another thing that seemed to be happening was that these kind of flashy signs of wealth were not celebrated anymore. I mean you had the sort of flashes in 1980s and you had, you know, some of that in the 2002 with the tech bubble and that really stopped being mainstream appropriate. And so of course we still have plutocrats and private jets and oligarchs and their yachts, but that that became more complicated for most elites. That type of landish material consumption and revealing of wealth was less interesting. Part of that is because the material goods that might show wealth in a day-to-day basis had become so commonplace.
社会地位的方式不再是物质的，或者不完全是物质的。另一个似乎正在发生的事情是，这种炫耀性的财富标志不再受庆祝了。我的意思是，你在20世纪80年代看到过这种炫耀，你知道的，在2002年科技泡沫时期也有一点，而这真的不再是主流得体的了。所以当然我们仍然有财阀、私人飞机、寡头和他们的游艇，但对于大多数精英来说，情况变得更加复杂了。这种荒唐的物质消费和财富展示变得不那么有趣了。部分原因是，在日常生活中能够展示财富的物质商品已经变得非常普遍。
Lots of people have nice cars and flats, green TVs. It used to be that when we thought about people who were in an elite social class, we often noticed who they were because of conspicuous consumption. You make the argument that I think a lot of people would find difficult to follow, which is that the new social class
很多人都有好车、公寓和平板电视。过去，当我们想到属于精英社会阶层的人时，我们经常通过炫耀性消费注意到他们是谁。你提出了一个我认为很多人会觉得很难理解的观点，那就是新社会阶层
or the new marker of social class is what you call inconspicuous consumption. What do you mean by that? So this all started because I wanted to look at who bought silver spoons in America today because Thorston Evelyn's famous example with it, you know, the wealthy bought silver spoons and even though they weren't more useful, in fact, people purchased them because they were a sign of status. So I just, you know, to be honest with you initially, thought it would be kind of fun to see who's
或社会阶层的新标志是你所谓的“隐性消费”。你这是什么意思？这一切的开始是因为我想看看今天美国是谁在买银勺子，因为托斯坦·凡勃伦的著名例子是，富人购买银勺子，尽管它们并没有更大的用处，事实上，人们购买它们是因为它们是地位的象征。所以我只是，老实说，最初觉得看看现在是谁在
buying silver spoons these days. And so I looked with my doctoral student, Jo Jung Lee, I looked at the consumer expenditure survey, and we looked at flatware, and we noticed that it was not this top 1% that was spending all of this money on flatware. And so it got me thinking about, well, what do the rich spend money on now? And here we have this big data set of all these consumer items. Let's find out. And what became really clear was that they were spending on things that weren't
买银勺子会挺有意思的。因此，我和我的博士生赵忠李一起查阅了消费者支出调查，我们研究了餐具，我们注意到并不是这前1%的人把所有的钱都花在餐具上。这让我开始思考，那么现在富人们把钱花在什么地方呢？这里我们有包含所有这些消费品的大型数据集。让我们找出来。显而易见的是，他们把钱花在那些并非
inherently material and obvious. And so the stats actually made me think more qualitatively about how the wealthy spend. And so you have tons and tons of stats showing that really, I mean, inconspicuous consumption. So consumption we can't necessarily see drives a lot of wealthy spending today. Whereas the middle class, and I mean this in the true sense, those in the 40th to 60th percentiles are spending on material goods. What did that qualitatively look like? And so I looked around and what you see is like. And so I looked around and what you see is this use of cultural capital to show social position and ways in which people talked wasn't about, you know, their fancy new car. It might be justified by it being diesel or it's electric and Pilates classes and then you look closely and are like, well, those are like, you know, 20 bucks a pop. Like how, like if people are going to those three days a week,
本质上是物质和显而易见的事物上。因此，这些统计数据实际上让我对富人如何消费进行了更定性的思考。所以你有成吨成吨的统计数据真正表明，我的意思是，隐性消费——也就是我们不一定能看到的消费——推动了今天富人的许多消费。而中产阶级——我的意思是真正的中产阶级，即处于第40到第60百分位数的人——则在物质商品上消费。这在定性上看起来是什么样的？所以我环顾四周，你看到的是。所以我环顾四周，你看到的是这种利用文化资本来展示社会地位的方式，人们谈论的方式不是关于他们的豪华新车。它可能是通过它是柴油车或电动车来合理化的，还有普拉提课程，然后你仔细一看会觉得，嗯，那些大概是，你知道的，二十块钱一节。像这样，如果人们一周去三次，
that's real money. And people buying all of this are organic food, which if you, you know, look in the grocery store, it's, you know, sometimes at least 50% more expensive than the conventional fruit. And yet, these became the practices that were inherently more expensive. And yet, they weren't screaming wealth in the
那可是一笔真正的钱。人们购买所有这些有机食品，如果你去杂货店看的话，你知道的，有时比传统水果贵至少50%。然而，这些却成为了本质上更昂贵的做法。然而，它们并没有像以往精英消费模式那样大声宣扬财富。我向伊丽莎白询问了人们购买的属于显性消费形式的东西的例子。豪车、昂贵的电子产品、昂贵的包包、真正昂贵的奢侈手表，以及隐形消费。
way that previous elite spending patterns might. I asked Elizabeth for examples of things that people purchased that would be conspicuous forms of consumption. Luxury cars, fancy electronics, fancy handbags, really, you know, expensive watches, and in conspicuous consumption. So education, nannies, gardeners, housekeepers, pensions, retirement, health care, these are things that people can't see. And yet, they're actually a lot more expensive than having a nice watch or a nice bag.
所以教育、保姆、园丁、管家、养老金、退休、医疗保健，这些都是人们看不到的东西。然而，它们实际上比一块好表或一个好包贵得多。
Elizabeth has noticed in her research a shift in spending patterns among the wealthiest or a nice bag. Elizabeth has noticed in her research a shift in spending patterns among the wealthiest Americans away from the flashy and to word the invisible. Like for example, breastfeeding. So we understand that it helps build their immunity when they're really small. My first child didn't get his first cold until a month after I stopped nursing and that was 16 months. Elizabeth Archeos at breastfeeding is an important marker of entry into this new social elite. When I became a mom I you know I immediately breastfed my kid and I
伊丽莎白在她的研究中注意到，最富有的美国人的消费模式发生了转变，从浮华转向无形。比如，母乳喂养。所以我们明白这有助于他们在很小的时候建立免疫力。我的第一个孩子直到我停止哺乳一个月后才第一次感冒，那是16个月大的时候。伊丽莎白认为母乳喂养是进入这个新社会精英阶层的标志。当我成为母亲时，你知道的，我立刻给我的孩子母乳喂养，我
signed up for mommy and me classes and you know my husband and I said oh we should definitely get an education fund started so that you know he can go to whatever college he wants to and the and breastfeeding by the way you know just like saving in a college fund were just the things that my friends did too. So everyone was just doing this and we didn't even question it. I mean everyone went to mommy in me classes and read to their kids from you know day one of life. And it pushed me to think about,
报名参加了亲子班，你知道的，我和丈夫说“哦，我们绝对应该设立一个教育基金，以便你知道他可以去他想去的任何大学”，顺便说一句，母乳喂养（就像存教育基金一样）只是我的朋友们也在做的事情。所以每个人都在这样做，我们甚至没有质疑它。我的意思是，每个人都去上亲子班，从生命的第一天起就给孩子读书。这促使我思考，
well, does everyone do this? And when you look at the data, you realize what a bubble you're in, right? You're in a bubble if you can save money at all. You're in a bubble if you can save for your kids' education. And you're in a bubble if you are breastfeeding your kids for six months to a year. And that made me realize that these were all signifiers
是不是每个人都这样做？当你查看数据时，你就会意识到你在一个多么大的泡沫里，对吧？如果你根本能存下钱，你就在一个泡沫里。如果你能为孩子的教育存钱，你就在一个泡沫里。如果你能给孩子母乳喂养六个月到一年，你就在一个泡沫里。这让我意识到，这些都是
of being a part of an educated class with good maternity leave and a decent salary. And that those were, again, markers of my social position. And they were for lots of people in my group. And if I actually never left my group or thought about it, I would just think that's how people behaved. And you realize that, wow, that's not everyone. And yet, in my world, it was everyone.
成为一个拥有良好产假和体面薪水的受教育阶层的一部分的标志。这些再次成为我社会地位的标志。对于我圈子里的很多人来说也是如此。如果我从未离开我的圈子或思考过这一点，我只会认为人们都是这样行为的。然后你意识到，哇，并不是每个人都这样。然而在我的世界里，每个人都这样。
So when you think about breastfeeding, it's interesting that you're thinking about it in terms of inconspicuous consumption because people would say, what's being consumed here, you're deciding to breastfeed your child, how is that consumption of any kind? Well, you're actually spending an awful lot of money to breastfeed your child because time is money today. And in a knowledge-driven economy where, frankly, the flexibility of work life is a product often of education and well-paid jobs and good maternity leave and good health benefits, that's expensive. And so that was the thing that really was interesting to me when I thought about how elite spend
所以当你想到母乳喂养时，有趣的是你会从隐性消费的角度来思考它，因为人们会说，这里消费了什么，你决定给你的孩子母乳喂养，这怎么能算任何形式的消费？嗯，为了母乳喂养你的孩子，你实际上花了很多钱，因为今天是时间就是金钱。在一个知识驱动的经济中，坦率地说，工作与生活的灵活性通常是教育、高薪工作、良好的产假和良好的健康福利的产物，而这代价高昂。这就是当我思考精英今天如何花钱时真正让我感兴趣的事情，那就是他们花钱是为了买回时间，花钱请园丁、育儿和家政服务，
money today is that they spend it to get time back, spending on gardeners and child care and housekeeping. that's what that is. I don't want to have to do this with my free time, and I have the money to not have to do it. And breastfeeding is something that is incredibly time intensive, and it takes a long time to get the hang of it for a lot, a lot of moms, and I'll add something else, and this is something from one of the sociologists I interviewed, you also have to be in a social world where you feel comfortable
事实就是这样。我不想在我的空闲时间里做这些，我有钱可以不用做。母乳喂养是一件极其耗费时间的事情，对很多很多妈妈来说，要掌握它需要很长时间，我还要补充一点——这是我采访的一位社会学家的话——如果你想在公共场合这样做，你还必须处于一个让你感到舒适的社会环境中。所以实际上所有这些都构建在，你知道的，身处一个让你感到安全并且有其他人也在这样做的环境中，再加上你投入到母乳喂养中的时间成本很高。我们已经讨论了生命前端的隐性消费。我想转向你在生命后端提到的另一个隐性消费的例子。在我们临终时，你发现现在穷人和富人在我们如何看待死亡以及如何举行葬礼方面存在着非常有趣的差异。
if you're going to do that in public. And so actually all of that is built into, you know, being in an environment where you feel that you're safe and that there's other people doing that, and then the fact that the time that you devote towards breastfeeding is expensive. So we've talked a little bit about inconspicuous consumption at the front end of life. I'd like to go to another example of inconspicuous consumption that you mentioned at the other end of life. At the time we die, you find there are really interesting differences now between rich and poor in how we think about death and how we conduct funerals.
如果你打算在公众场合这样做。实际上，所有这些都建立在一种环境中，你知道，在这个环境中你觉得自己是安全的，而且有其他人也在这样做，然后你投入母乳喂养的时间成本是很高的。所以我们前面讨论了一点关于人生初期的不显眼消费。我想谈谈你提到的关于人生另一端的不显眼的消费的另一个例子。在我们临终的时候，你会发现现在富人和穷人在我们如何看待死亡以及如何举行葬礼方面存在着非常有趣的差异。
rich and poor in how we think about death and how we conduct funerals. Yes, so what is the interesting statistics or findings in in my analysis is that the poor spend over a quarter more on funerals than the rich. I was stumped by this finding to be perfectly honest. So I asked my colleague David Sloan, who's a historian at the University of Southern California, and he is written on funerals and cemeteries, and I said, what to make of this? And so, as he explained it to me, one of the things that happens is that poor families have much greater social capital. And so, the funeral becomes a very, very important center of, you know, social
富人和穷人在我们如何看待死亡以及如何举行葬礼方面存在着非常有趣的差异。是的，所以在我的分析中，有趣的统计数据或发现是，穷人在葬礼上的花费比富人多四分之一以上。说实话，我被这个发现难住了。所以我问了我的同事大卫·斯隆，他是南加州大学的历史学家，他写过关于葬礼和墓地的文章，我说，这该如何理解？正如他向我解释的那样，发生的情况之一是穷人家庭拥有大得多的社会资本。因此，葬礼成为一个非常非常重要的社会
gathering, you know, even if it's, of course, solemn and it's honoring the person who just died, that it does become a place for the entire community to come together. And, you know, think about, sort of conventionally, like the Irish wake, for example. And so it then has these performative aspects, right? So it's about, you know, showing the honor towards the person who's died, making a big deal. It's also that you have more people there. So it becomes a much bigger event than it does for wealthier families. There are also class differences in burial practices.
聚会中心（你知道的，即使它当然是庄严的，并且是在缅怀刚刚去世的人），它确实成为了整个社区聚集在一起的地方。而且，你知道的，传统上可以想想爱尔兰的守灵，例如。所以它随后具有了这些表演性的方面，对吧？所以它是关于展示对死者的敬意，大肆操办。这也是因为你在那里有更多的人。因此，它比富裕家庭的葬礼变成了一个大得多的活动。葬礼习俗也存在阶级差异。
I would like to be cremated. I think burial is a poor use of land space. I would want to be cremated, I think. Well, it has become my family standard to be cremated. And I think it has a lot to do with a sense of an overcrowded planet. Increasingly, cremating the dead has become a signifier of class. Yes, so this is another interesting distinction between the rich and the poor. The rich cremate more and the poor bury more.
我希望被火化。我认为土葬是对土地空间的不良利用。我想我会选择火化。嗯，火化已经成为我们家族的标准。我认为这与对地球过度拥挤的意识有很大关系。越来越多的人将死者火化已经成为了阶级的标志。是的，所以这是富人和穷人之间的另一个有趣区别。富人火化多，穷人土葬多。
And again, I was stumped by this. But again, when I spoke with my colleague, David, he said, well, it's because they have very different attitudes towards death. And the wealthy tend to keep it very private. And this, of course, inherently lowers its expenses. You might extend this to this idea that the poor have greater amounts of social capital. And so again, the concentration of people coming makes it more expensive.
同样，我被难住了。但再次当我与我的同事大卫交谈时，他说，嗯，这是因为他们对死亡有非常不同的态度。富人倾向于把它保持得非常私密。当然，这本身就降低了开支。你可以把这延伸到这个观点：穷人拥有更多的社会资本。因此，聚集的人群使得它更加昂贵。
And that they actually, the richer and the more educated you are, is the more likely you are to cremate. And I don't know what this is. I mean, is this correlated to religion? Is it correlated to beliefs in the afterlife? I don't know, but it's clearly there's a larger trend that wealthier people not only want something private, but they also have a different philosophy
而且实际上，你越富有、受教育程度越高，你就越有可能选择火化。我不知道这是什么。我的意思是，这与宗教有关吗？这与对来世的信仰有关吗？我不知道，但显然存在一个更大的趋势：较富裕的人不仅想要私密，而且他们也有不同的哲学
about what to do when someone dies. When we come back, how these choices add up to the creation of a new social elite, and why some wealthy people feel guilty about being rich. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthu. This week we're talking about elite groups. Elizabeth Carrad-Halkit has been studying the spending patterns of the wealthiest Americans. She finds them moving away from things like fancy cars and giant TVs, and instead spending their time and money on breastfeeding, organic food, and education. My children are the recipients of the most expensive
关于当有人去世时该怎么做。当我们回来时，这些选择是如何共同创造出一个新的社会精英阶层的，以及为什么一些富有的人会对自己的富有感到内疚。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。本周我们讨论的是精英群体。伊丽莎白·卡拉德-哈尔基特一直在研究美国最富有的人群的消费模式。她发现他们正在远离像豪车和巨型电视这样的大件物品，而是将时间和金钱花在母乳喂养、有机食品和教育上。我的孩子们是世界上历史上最昂贵的
education in the history of the world. Stepping back to look at the big picture of Elizabeth's research, you can see how privilege replicates itself. From the earliest days of someone's life, there are the breastfed or formula fed. Maybe that one thing doesn't make a big difference, but as they grow up, their parents are buying organic tomatoes or conventional tomatoes. They get signed up for piano classes or they don't.
教育的接受者。退一步看伊丽莎白研究的大局，你可以看到特权是如何自我复制的。从一个人生命的最早几天开始，就有母乳喂养或配方奶喂养。也许单凭这一件事并不能带来巨大的改变，但随着他们长大，他们的父母会买有机西红柿或普通西红柿。他们会被报名参加钢琴班，或者没有。
Their parents are able to save for their college education or they're not. Elizabeth argues that each of these small decisions adds up. It creates a new social elite. These behaviors and practices reinforce their privilege and reinforce the privilege of their children in a way that superficial material goods don't pass on from generation to generation. One of the people that is very interesting to consider when looking at this class is Pierre-Bordier's concept of habitats.
他们的父母能够为他们的大学教育存钱，或者不能。伊丽莎白认为，这些小决定中的每一个都在累积。它创造了一个新的社会精英阶层。这些行为和做法巩固了他们的特权，并以一种表面物质商品无法代代相传的方式巩固了他们孩子的特权。在考虑这一阶层时，非常有趣的一个观点是皮埃尔·布尔迪厄的惯习概念。
So he argued that he was a great thinker on cultural capital, and he argued that there were these physical manifestations of cultural capital. And so yoga, breastfeeding, binaurganic food, attending farmers markets, listening to NPR, reading the books on the New York Times bestseller list, these are all physical manifestations of your cultural capital, right? They show your education, they show that you have time, and they implicitly show you have money. The thing that I think is most cause for concern with the rise of what I call the aspirational class
所以他认为，他是文化资本的一位伟人，他认为文化资本有这些物质表现形式。因此，瑜伽、母乳喂养、纯有机食品、逛农夫市场、听NPR、阅读《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上的书，这些都是你文化资本的物质表现，对吧？它们展示了你的教育，它们表明你有时间，并且它们含蓄地表明你有钱。我认为随着我所说的抱负阶层的崛起最令人担忧的事情是
is that there is a kind of belief that all of these practices are actually for the good, for the good of society. You know, I'm putting money away for education for my child. I'm breastfeeding my child. That's what my doctor told my son's pediatrician told me to do. I am practicing yoga, which makes me healthier, which is important. And then there becomes this ignorance
存在这样一种信念，即所有这些做法实际上都是为了好事，为了社会的利益。你知道，我正在为我孩子的教育存钱。我在母乳喂养我的孩子。那是我的医生、我儿子的儿科医生告诉我要做的。我在练习瑜伽，这让我更健康，这很重要。然后这就变成了一种无知
to the fact that others can't do this. So I find breastfeeding to be a particularly fascinating one because in my bubble of motherhood, everyone breastfeed, the thing that I have found with some of my friends who are mothers in this social group is they actually feel really bad when they have to stop and they feel embarrassed if they have to introduce formula because they have to go back to work and so suddenly I, you
忽视了其他人无法做到这一点的现实。因此，我发现母乳喂养是一个特别迷人的例子，因为在我的母亲身份泡沫中，每个人都母乳喂养，我从一些身为母亲的朋友身上发现，在这个社会群体中，当她们不得不停止时，她们实际上会感到非常糟糕，如果因为必须重返工作岗位而不得不引入配方奶，她们会感到尴尬，所以突然之间，我，你
know, you know, writing this book, I was thinking why would you feel bad about any of this? I mean this is this doesn't make sense to feel bad about this and so you realize that this is a signifier of a particular type of motherhood that they espoused you. I want to talk about one specific aspect of inconspicuous consumption that is really striking, and in some ways might actually be at the heart of many of the other things that you're mentioning. And that's education. You say that the top 10% of Americans have increased their share of educational expenditures by almost 300% between 1996 and 2014, while the poor are spending essentially the same amount
知道，在写这本书的时候，我在想，为什么你会对这一切感到难过？我的意思是，这根本没有理由感到难过，所以你意识到这是他们所信奉的一种特定母亲形象的标志。我想谈谈无形消费的一个特定方面，它非常引人注目，在某些方面实际上可能是你提到的许多其他事情的核心。那就是教育。你说在1996年至2014年期间，美国前10%的人口将其教育支出的份额增加了近300%，而穷人在教育上的支出基本上与
as they've always spent on education at the same since 1996, despite higher tuition cost, higher education costs. Let's just talk about education for a second and stay with this idea. What are the effects do you think of this increasing disparity in how people are investing and value education? The thing about education is that it essentially sets a child up for future success in the workplace, right? So, you know, historically, if we think about the middle class of the 20th century,
1996年以来的支出保持相同，尽管学费成本、高等教育成本更高。让我们仅仅讨论一下教育一分钟，并坚持这个想法。你认为人们在教育投资和价值观念上的这种日益扩大的差距会带来什么影响？关于教育的事情是，它基本上为一个孩子在职场的未来成功奠定了基础，对吧？所以，你知道，从历史上看，如果我们想想20世纪的中产阶级，
you know, something like under 10% of men had college degrees. And now, the overall population is something like 33% of people have a college degree. So, college degrees have become essential for social mobility and these knowledge-driven jobs, whether you're working for NPR or you're working as a professor or you're working as a banker, they require college degrees, often graduate degrees, and so being able to send your child to college essentially, it doesn't ensure, but it certainly increases the likelihood greatly that you will pass on that social mobility. You will give them a chance.
你知道，差不多不到10%的男性拥有大学学位。现在，整个人口中大约有33%的人拥有大学学位。因此，大学学位对于社会流动性变得至关重要，这些知识驱动的工作，无论你是在NPR工作，还是担任教授，或者你是一名银行家，它们都需要大学学位，通常是研究生学位，所以能够把你的孩子送进大学基本上，它虽然不能保证，但肯定大大增加了你传递这种社会流动性的可能性。你将给他们一个机会。
The part of this that is alarming is that it's so, so expensive. So if you look at the increase in the cost of all sorts of goods, I think it's 10 years, education has increased 80% in its cost, and that is so hard for people to write checks for. Even if you're in the upper middle class, it's hard. And so, that is part of the problem with education as being a status good now is that in fact it's not just the moment in time of status, it's the reproduction of the privilege. And I would add one more thing to that. You know, part of how you apply to universities these days is that you have this very wonderful, culturally rich mosaic of a person, right? So they've traveled abroad and they maybe they've taken
这其中令人担忧的部分在于它太贵了。因此，如果你看看各种商品成本的增长，我认为是10年间，教育的成本增加了80%，这对人们来说很难开出支票。即使你处于中产阶级上层，这也很难。因此，这就是教育现在作为一种地位商品存在的问题的一部分，事实上，它不仅是那一刻的地位，而且是特权的再生产。我要再加上一点。你知道，如今申请大学的部分过程是，你拥有一个非常美妙、文化丰富的个人马赛克，对吧？所以他们出国旅行过，可能还参加过
piano or violin lessons, they have fabulous, I say, T scores, they've gone to a pretty good high school, there's this whole package and I think that that matters more and more. It matters a lot more than when I apply to university, I can say that. And those things cost a lot of money. And you can see it. So for example, the top 1%, then 20 times more on musical instruments than the middle class. In fact, they spend five times more than the rest of the top 10%.
钢琴或小提琴课程，他们有我说的极好的标准化考试成绩，他们去过一所相当不错的高中，这是一个完整的组合，我认为这越来越重要。这比我申请大学时重要得多，我可以这么说。而这些东西要花很多钱。你可以看到它。例如，前1%的人在乐器上的花费是中产阶级的20倍。事实上，他们的花费是其他前10%的人的五倍。
So if you think about the way in which we get this cultural capital that is so important in the college application process. That is also expensive. And I'll add one other thing that is not my own data. This is Raj Chadi from Stanford. They looked at elite bachelor's degree. So they used Ivy Leagues. And they found that if you were in the top 1%,
因此，如果你想想我们在大学申请过程中获得这种如此重要的文化资本的方式。这也是昂贵的。我还要补充一点，这不是我自己的数据。这是斯坦福大学的拉吉·切蒂。他们研究了精英本科学位。因此，他们使用了常春藤盟校。他们发现，如果你在前1%中，
you were 77 times more likely to attend an Ivy League than if your parents were in an income group outside of the top 1%. So here's a paradox Elizabeth. And in some ways I think asking this question might betray my own class membership in terms of the aspirational class. But isn't there some intrinsic value in breastfeeding and learning the piano and in investing in education and investing in retirement and making environmentally conscious choices? I mean, the thing that I find tricky
你上常春藤盟校的可能性是没有进入前1%的父母的收入群体的孩子的77倍。所以，伊丽莎白，这里有一个悖论。在某些方面，我认为提出这个问题可能会暴露出我自己在抱负阶层中的阶级归属。但是母乳喂养、学习钢琴、投资教育、投资退休以及做出环保的选择难道没有一些内在价值吗？我的意思是，我发现棘手的事情是
is that in some ways it seems like you're launching a critique of these practices. When many of the practices arguably have something good to say for them. And of course, at the top of that list, I'd say listening to NPR. This is a great question. And again, I will reveal my own class position. I do all of these things that I write about.
在某些方面，这似乎是在对这些做法进行批判。而许多这些做法可以说是无可厚非的。当然，在这个名单的顶部，我会说听NPR。这是一个很好的问题。而且，我将再次暴露我自己的阶级地位。我做所有这些我写下来的事情。
You know, my child started piano at the age of four. You know, we save for college. I breastfed my child over a year, both of them. I practice Pilates, so I am as guilty as you and not just engaging these practices, but also believing that they are the right uses of my time and money. But the thing that was important for me, as I wrote this book, was to think about how you get access to do these things and who doesn't, who doesn't. Because it's really clear when you're dealing with a Rolex
你知道，我的孩子四岁开始学钢琴。你知道，我们为大学存钱。我母乳喂养我的孩子超过一年，两个都是。我练习普拉提，所以我和你一样有罪，不仅参与这些实践，而且还相信它们是对我时间和金钱的正当使用。但对我来说重要的是，当我写这本书时，是去思考你是如何获得做这些事情的机会的，以及谁没有，谁没有。因为当你处理一块劳力士时，这真的很清楚
that unless you have $5,000 to $20,000, you can't wear a Rolex watch, OK? But it's just a watch, right? I mean, maybe you give it to your okay? But it's just a watch, right? I mean, maybe you give it to your son, but it's just a watch. But when I looked at these practices, I thought, this isn't just a watch. These are things that are really good.
除非你有5,000到20,000美元，否则你戴不起劳力士手表，对吧？但这只是一块手表，对吧？我的意思是，也许你把它送给你的，好吧？但这只是一块手表，对吧？我的意思是，也许你把它送给你的儿子，但它只是一块手表。但是当我审视这些做法时，我想，这不仅仅是一块手表。这些都是真正有益的事情。
They're really important. But part of the fact that they are so important is why they really set the stage for the next generation. And the luxury to do them, I think, in many ways, the people who participate in these practices, who are members of the aspirational class, aren't fully aware necessarily of how privileged we are to be able to do these things. And how difficult it is to do these things if you don't have the education to know that x, y, and Z should be done or you don't have the income to write
它们非常重要。但它们之所以如此重要，部分原因在于它们确实为下一代奠定了基础。并且我认为，在许多方面，参与这些实践的人，即抱负阶层的成员，并不完全意识到我们能够做这些事情是多么特权。如果你没有受过教育去知道X、Y和Z应该做，或者你没有收入去写
the check to do them. So one of the things that I think is kind of interesting about these practices is that we, you know, there's a sort of obliviousness. It's a very good nature to obliviousness, but it is. It's a, well, I'm just doing these things because they're good for my family and they're good for the environment. But there is still this reproduction that adds to inequality. So if you're buying organic food and you're breastfeeding your kid and you're exercising, you probably think you're doing the right thing in society. You're doing nothing wrong and you're listening to NPR so you know what's going on in the world and you probably read the New York Times and you feel updated and you feel that you are on the right side of things. And if we actually think about, you know, for example, what happened with the election
支票来做这些事情，那是多么困难。因此，我认为这些实践中比较有趣的一点是，我们，你知道，有一种健忘。这是一种非常自然的健忘，但确实是。这是一种，“嗯，我只是在做这些事情，因为它们对我的家庭有益，对环境有益。”但仍然存在这种导致不平等的再生产。因此，如果你在买有机食品，你在母乳喂养你的孩子，你在锻炼，你可能认为你在为社会做正确的事情。你没有做错任何事，你在听NPR，所以你知道世界上正在发生什么，你可能读《纽约时报》，你觉得自己了解最新信息，你觉得你站在正确的一边。如果我们实际上考虑，你知道，例如，选举发生了什么
and, you know, a lot of liberal elites were shocked. Oh my goodness, how did this happen? And actually, if you step outside of one of those liberal elite bubbles, you completely see how it happened. People don't think like this. They don't necessarily have the same practices, and they actually, in some ways, resent the exclusion. That is just even if it's accidental is very, very obvious for people who are not members of the aspirational class. Elizabeth Carrot-Halcott is a professor at the University of Southern California. She's the author of Starstruck and the sum of small things, a theory of the aspirational class.
并且，你知道，许多自由派精英都惊呆了。哦天哪，这怎么会发生？实际上，如果你走出其中一个自由派精英泡沫，你就会完全明白它是怎么发生的。人们不这样想。他们不一定有相同的做法，而且在某些方面，他们对这种排斥感到不满。对于那些不是抱负阶层成员的人来说，这种排斥即使是偶然的，也是非常非常明显的。伊丽莎白·卡拉德-哈尔基特是南加州大学的教授。她是《势利》和《微小事物的总和：抱负阶层的理论》的作者。
If you're feeling a bit sheepish after hearing about this research and you're wondering whether your choices to go to yoga classes and by organic produce are problematic, you're not alone. Erin Beaton is an assistant professor at Ohio State University. She studies inequality. She offers us this commentary on the conflicting emotions people feel about their wealth. My husband and I don't go to church, but we wanted to have some sort of Sunday routine, so I tracked down an emergency shelter and asked a volunteer.
如果你在听到这项研究后感到有点羞愧，并且想知道你去上瑜伽课和买有机农产品的选择是否有问题，你并不孤单。艾琳·比顿是俄亥俄州立大学的助理教授。她研究不平等。她为我们提供了关于人们对财富的矛盾情感的评论。我和我丈夫不去教堂，但我们想有一些周日的常规活动，所以我找到了一家紧急避难所并询问了一名志愿者。
We go down there at 5.30 every Sunday, and for about 90 minutes my husband and I stand side by side as people shuffle past, holding out styrofoam plates. He serves the vegetables, I serve the entre and some bread. The food. What can I say about the food? Some days it's noodles and chicken with some corn. My husband and I look at one another as we serve the meals. We'd eat this food if we had to, but definitely not if we had choice. The people we serve take plastic bottles of hot sauce back to their tables and slather their food with it.
我们每个星期天下午5:30去那里，大约90分钟里，我和丈夫并肩站着，看着人们从旁边走过，手里拿着泡沫塑料盘。他负责分发蔬菜，我负责分发主食和一些面包。食物。关于食物我能说些什么？有些日子是面条和鸡肉加一些玉米。我和丈夫在分发食物时互相看了一眼。如果我们不得不吃，我们会吃这些食物，但绝对不是在有选择的情况下。我们服务的人把塑料瓶装的辣酱带回他们的桌子上，并在食物上涂满了辣酱。
I remember one woman in line. She must have been in her 40s. She looked very, very tired. My husband's an extroverted man and he cheerfully greeted her with, how's it going? She stared at him. No, that's not right. She clared at him. Finally he asked,
我记得队伍里的一位女士。她一定有40多岁了。她看起来非常非常疲惫。我丈夫是一个外向的人，他愉快地跟她打招呼：“最近怎么样？”她盯着他看。不，那不对。她怒视着他。最后他问，
was that an inappropriate question? She nodded, yes. After we're done at the shelter, we go out to dinner ourselves. Usually sushi. We sit at the bar and I order spicy tuna, rainbow rolls, dragon rolls. My husband likes anything with tempura. He orders craft beer. If it's hot outside, I have a glass of shardinay. If it's cold, I like pino noir. We talk about the evening and the contrast between the meal we're having now and the one
这是一个不恰当的问题吗？她点了点头，是的。我们在避难所忙完后，自己出去吃晚饭。通常是寿司。我们坐在吧台旁，我点辣金枪鱼卷、彩虹卷、火龙卷。我丈夫喜欢任何有天妇罗的东西。他点精酿啤酒。如果外面热，我喝一杯霞多丽。如果冷，我喜欢黑皮诺。我们谈论着今晚的经历，以及我们现在吃的饭菜与我们
we just served. I feel guilt. Worse, I feel shame. I recognize this feeling. As an ethnographer, I've conducted research into the behavior of the very wealthy. In one study, my colleagues and I spoke with wealthy people who are interested in combating inequality. We usually think of the very wealthy as uncaring and selfish, but the people I studied
刚刚服务的饭菜之间的鲜明对比。我感到内疚。更糟的是，我感到羞耻。我认出了这种感觉。作为一名民族志学者，我对超级富豪的行为进行了研究。在一项研究中，我和同事们与有兴趣打击不平等的富人进行了交谈。我们通常认为超级富豪冷酷自私，但我研究过的人
sound a lot like my husband and I do at the sushi bar. They're stricken. Some of them are self-made entrepreneurs, but still, they feel guilty. And it's worse for those who inherited their wealth. One rich woman confessed that it was much harder for her to admit to being wealthy than to come out as a lesbian. All of us live in worlds of our own. We spend time with people who look like us, who go to the same schools. We do this not only because we get along easily with people like us, but because those people
听起来很像我和我丈夫在寿司吧的表现。他们感到痛苦。他们中有些人是白手起家的创业者，但他们仍然感到内疚。对于那些继承财富的人来说，情况更糟糕。一位富有的女性坦言，承认自己富有比出柜承认自己是女同性恋要难得多。我们所有人都生活在各自的世界里。我们和那些看起来像我们、去同一所学校的人在一起。我们这样做不仅是因为我们很容易和像我们这样的人相处，还因为这些人
allow us to see ourselves the way we see ourselves. When I talk to someone who moves in the same circles I do, I recognize myself. When I look at myself through those eyes, that Aaron I'm familiar with. When I look at myself through the eyes of that exhausted woman at the shelter, I see an unfamiliar version of myself, the privileged Aaron. Few of us are willing to break outside our social networks. It's not comfortable to look at the world and ourselves differently. One reason privilege endures is because those of us who have it are often unconscious of it. This is what makes the hard work of getting out of our comfort zones so important.
让我们能够以我们看待自己的方式来看待自己。当我与一个和我处于相同社交圈子的人交谈时，我认出了自己。当我通过那些眼睛看着自己时，那个艾琳是我熟悉的。当我通过避难所那个疲惫女人的眼睛看着自己时，我看到了一个不熟悉的自己，那个享有特权的艾琳。很少有人愿意打破我们的社交网络。看着世界和不同的自己并不舒服。特权之所以持久的一个原因是因为拥有特权的人往往对此毫无意识。这就是走出舒适区这一艰苦工作如此重要的原因。
If you want to create a more equitable world, the first thing you must do is to step outside. Aaron Beaton is an assistant professor at Ohio State University. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Renee Clark, Jenny Schmidt and Parts Cha. Our unsung heroes this week are Jonathan Gang, Ann Neu Sanny and Maria Bollinska at the conversation. The conversation is a news and commentary website that helps bring great ideas from academics
如果你想创造一个更公平的世界，你必须做的第一件事就是走出去。艾琳·比顿是俄亥俄州立大学的助理教授。这一期的《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·佩恩曼和雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括蕾妮·克拉克、珍妮·施密特和帕茨·查。我们本周的无名英雄是《对话》杂志的乔纳森·甘、安·纽·萨尼和玛丽亚·博林斯卡。《对话》是一个新闻和评论网站，帮助将学者们的伟大想法带给
to the general public. Jonathan Ann and Maria help produce Erin Beaton's commentary in today's episode. You can sign up for the conversation's newsletter at theconvacation.com slash newsletter. You can also follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories and morning edition on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
普通大众。乔纳森、安和玛丽亚协助制作了今天节目中艾琳·比顿的评论。你可以在theconversation.com/newsletter上注册《对话》的通讯。你还可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台的早间新闻节目中收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。